so this isn't really so much a debt
crisis as it is a strategy by the
European authorities of first of all
regime change they want to get rid of
the government that the Greek people
voted for and they've created starting
two weeks ago an actual hostage
situation where they shut down they
forced a shutdown of the Greek banking
system which you can imagine what that
would be like here with people go to the
bank and the most you can get is fifty
fifty sixty dollars out of your ATM
they've done all this to force the Greek
people to accept their terms and
political terms especially changing the
kind of society they have and they're
doing it through this kind of brute
force the European authorities since the
world financial crisis and recession
have used this weakness in some of the
economies in Europe to try and change
Europe they want it to be the society
that's more like the US with less of a
social safety net with lower pensions
with a weaker labor movement with more
inequality that's the kind of societies
that they've been trying to create it's
kind of like waterboarding you know
where they're trying to make the victim
feel like they're drowning but not
actually kill them and that's kind of
what they've done by shutting down the
banking system and really forced the
near meltdown of the economy now they
could even accidentally go so far as
they do force a financial meltdown which
pushes Greece out of the euro even if
they don't intend to do it
increase were forced out of the euro
things would get worse before they would
get better because there would be a
financial crisis but there is life after
financial crises and they would recover
once the financial system was stabilized
and it is possible and I would say even
likely that they would recover faster
outside of the euro then the European
authorities are going to allow them to
recover right now
you